AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME, THE
PLEASURE IS MINE.
( APPLAUSE )
LET'S SLOW IT DOWN, BECAUSE THIS
STORY IS FOR THE LADIES.
THANK YOU, LADY.
( CHEERS )
MADAM, PLEASE!
THIS IS A FAMILY PROGRAM!
AND FAMILIES COME FROM
( BLEEP ).
SORRY, I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY.
THE SWEDISH ASSOCIATION FOR
SEXUALITY EDUCATION LAUNCHED A
COMPETITION TO FIND A NEW WORD
FOR FEMALE MASTURBATION AND ONE
BUZZWORD BUZZED ITS WAY TO A BIG
FINISH.
THE WINNING WORD TO DO THAT
THING THAT YOU DO AFTER YOUR
BOYFRIEND FALLS ASLEEP BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT SATISFIED IS CALLED
KLITTRA, KLITTRA.
COMBINATION OF CLITORIS AND
GLLITER.
BUT IT JUST SOUNDS LIKE A
THUNDERCAT.
THE MOST ELUSIVE AND SENSITIVE
OF THE THUNDERCATS.
COME UP WITH MORE TERMS FOR
FEMALE MASTURBATION.
LET'S POPULATE IT SO IT'S NOT
JUST ONE WORD.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK AND BEGIN.
CAMERON.
>> GOING ALL HILLARY ON YOUR
BILL OF RIGHTS.
>> THE CLITTYS-BURG ADDRESS.
>> SWIFFING THE PINK TILE FLOOR.
>> HOME ALONING.
>> DJING YOUR OWN PANTS PARTY.
>> CHANNING MY TATUM.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> THANK YOU.
>> CHRIS: JUST SAYING IT MAKES
MASTURBATING MOOT.
THEY ALL JUST (BLEEP).
CAMERON.
>> OR PUT SOME MAGIC ON YOUR
MIKE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
CAMERON.
>> WINNING THE WOMEN'S WORLD
CUP.
>> CHRIS: YES!
SO GOOD!